en agriculture il y a beaucoup de choses
qu'on ne contrôle pas à commencer par la
météo est désormais les fermiers
canadiens doivent composer avec une
crise diplomatique entre la chine et le
canada une crise sur laquelle ils n'ont
aucune emprise et qui entraîne pourtant
de lourdes pertes pour eux
[Musique]
et
au coeur de la vallée de la rivière
rouge au manitoba gilbert ce bourg est
inculte yves dugré sur 500 hectares
traite en 2019 il fonde beaucoup
d'espoir sur les récoltes à venir
il se remet encore de l'année précédente
vu ses profits s'évaporer sous le soleil
d'une sécheresse qui a réduit ses
rendements de 40%
mais gilbert c'est bourré ne pourra
miser cette année sur l'île de ces
cultures vedette le canola limité
c'est que le prix du canola a chuté de
12% en quelques semaines et rien
n'indique qu'il remontera de sitôt c'est
juste le commencement de ce qui se passe
là ça fait pas vendre de canaux et des
angles inédits
depuis le printemps dernier le canola
canadien a perdu ses lettres de noblesse
dans les champs des prairies au grand
dam des producteurs de grains
[Musique]
tout a basculé pour eux en décembre 2018
cette scène captée par une caméra de
surveillance à l'aéroport de vancouver
aura un grand impact sur l'économie
canadienne
la directrice financière du géant des
télécommunications huawei manjoo est
arrêté par les autorités canadiennes sur
une demande d'extradition des états unis
[Musique]
malgré les protestations du gouvernement
chinois
elle est assignée à résidence en attente
d'une audience sur la demande
d'extradition
quelques semaines plus tard au quartier
général de reach de sementina genou
laouni peg l'une des plus importantes
sociétés d'exportation céréalière au
pays une nouvelle secoue l'entreprise la
chine révoque à compter du 1er mars
son permis d'importation de canola sur
son territoire les dirigeants de rich
wilson sont bouleversés c'était une
surprise pour nous on voulait essayer de
comprendre de quoi il s'agit c'est à ce
moment là on nous disait que c'était une
question de il y avait des allégations
de de qualité le gouvernement chinois
affirme que des parasites ont été
trouvés dans des cargaisons de canola
canadien les allégations prod nous a
semblait pas très crédible
c'était vraiment à court terme essayer
de voir qu'est-ce qu'on était pour faire
avec nos exportations a essayé
d'éteindre les feux si on veut
puis limité à les pertes trois semaines
plus tard l'entreprise agroalimentaire
21 heures à elle à son tour son permis
d'importation de canola en chine
ensemble les deux sociétés va terra et
rich chine exporte les trois quarts du
canola canadien vendus en chine
ça a été un peu soulagement de constater
qu'il s'agissait de quelque chose de
plus grand que je suis toute seule
nous avions l'impression à ce moment là
que nous souhaitons pour être une
question quelle est la durée
[Musique]
la chine est de loin le plus important
acheteur de canola canadien 50% du
canola exportés par le canada et vendus
en chine en 2018
cela a représenté près de 5 millions de
tonnes d'une valeur de 2 milliards 700
millions de dollars
l'impact de l'effondrement du marché
avec la chine sur le prix de la récolte
est dit médian
à la fin janvier 2019 le canola se
vendait 490 dollars la tonne au début
mai le prix avaient chuté à 430 dollars
une baisse de 12% chez les producteurs
de grains c'est la consternation
le canola est la source de revenus la
plus important pour eux depuis une
dizaine d'années dans les deux suis
canadien de que nous vivons sur les
exploitations
brahim nice et le vice président du
conseil canadien du canola lacanau les
suivants pour des producteurs à l'ouest
du canada a commandé à la cache la cci
où se trouve le mage pour soutenir le
faire
[Musique]
à saint jean baptiste au manitoba
gilbert sabourin conserver dans notre
poule dimino de canola de ses récoltes
de 2018
une récolte qui n'était pas sous contrat
[Musique]
ils attendaient le bon prix pour vendre
ses gré à une usine locale de
transformation pour aider à payer ces
semences de 2019
il devra maintenant vendre ce canola à
pertes éventuellement pour faire du cash
flow
ces deux trois pièces du minot de moins
c'est 20 à 30000 places le moins on
prête en 2019
il a réduit le nombre d'hectares semer
en canola de 15% et il a remplacé cette
culture perd plus d'avoine et de maïs et
il n'est pas seul
les producteurs de grains canadien on se
met en moyenne 10% - de canola cette
année soit environ 600 mille hectares
une superficie plus grande que celle de
l'est du prince édouard
le problème c'est que le canola n'est
pas la seule culture affecté par la
crise diplomatique avec le gouvernement
chinois
en temps normal la chaîne achète aussi
60% du soya canadiens destinés à
l'exportation des ventes d'une valeur de
près de 2 milliards de dollars par année
or les clients chinois ont aussi cessé
presque complètement l'importation de
soya canadien depuis janvier 2019
à la fin mars près de 3 millions de
tonnes de soya se trouvaient dans les
entrepôts des fermiers et des
exportateurs en attente d'un contrat de
vente des stocks record pour cette
culture dont le prix a baissé d'environ
8%
les exportateurs tente de trouver de
nouveaux marchés pour ses récoltes un
million de tonnes additionnelles de
canola par exemple ont été vendus en
europe cette année
mais il est difficile voire impossible
de remplacer complètement un marché de
la taille de la chine
[Musique]
certains craignent que le canada ne
perde pour toujours sa part du marché
chinois puisque les acheteurs doivent
maintenant se tourner vers des
oléagineux provenant d'ailleurs c'est
toujours difficile à faire des
changements avec une compagnie qui
transforme des produits agroalimentaires
une délégation chinoise a d'ailleurs
visité l'argentine en nous dans le but
d'acheter pour la première fois du
tourtour de soutien en provenance de ce
pays la chine achetées en 2018 un
million et demi de tonnes de tourteaux
de canola canadien
fake ou 2019 début des récoltes dans le
sud du manitoba
[Musique]
les champs de maïs et d'avoine sur la
ferme de gilbert sabourin ont souffert
en raison d'un autre était beaucoup trop
sec
les rendements seront bien inférieurs à
la moyenne
visiblement déçus les producteurs de
grains c'est qu'une récolte normale de
canola lui aurait permis d'atténuer ses
pertes
la voisine d'école qui prend beaucoup
d'obtenir sa saison tandis que le cône
aura besoin un peu moins d'eau alors là
oui mon canot à réguler et jada pas man
meilleur d'école la crise actuelle
pourrait coûter un milliard de dollars
aux fermiers canadiens en 2019 selon le
conseil du canola gilbert sabouret sait
déjà que ses revenus seront réduits de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
dollars
et il n'est guère plus optimiste
lorsqu'il pense aux années à venir je
pense que tout cela dommage ici c'est
perlman a doté ce père qui en manquent
de l'école ailleurs dans le monde faire
d'augmenter les prix
les producteurs de grains ne sont pas
les seuls à faire les frais de la crise
diplomatique avec le géant chinois
depuis le 25 juin les exportations de
porc canadien vers la chine sont
suspendues
une situation qui survient à un bien
mauvais moment c'est que la chaîne est
aux prises avec la peste porcine
africaine
une maladie qui lui a déjà fait perdre
100 millions de porcs c'est le tiers de
son cheptel
elle a donc plus besoin que jamais du
port étranger